INFLATION, ENERGY, OPEN BORDERS,
UKRAINE, CHINA, SO MUCH MORE.
BUT FIRST, BIG NEWS FROM THE
PRESIDENT'S HOMETOWN OF
NEW YORK CITY, OR FORMER
HOMETOWN, WHERE A MAN NAMED
FRANK JAMES HAS BEEN APPREHENDED
AFTER ALLEGEDLY FIRING OVER 30
ROUNDS INTO A CROWDED SUBWAY AND
BROOKLYN, NEW YORK, SHOOTING TEN
COMMUTERS.
TONIGHT, THE PERPETRATORS
TWISTED MOTIVES AND IDEOLOGY ARE
COMING INTO FOCUS ON WHAT A
SERIES OF DERANGED VIDEOS FILLED
WITH VIOLENT RHETORIC POSTED ON
YOUTUBE WHILE JAMES WAS
BRILLIANT AGAINST WHITE PEOPLE,
ASIAN AMERICANS, JEWISH
AMERICANS, HISPANIC AMERICANS,
AND THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA.
EVEN TRASH JOE BIDEN
SUPREME COURT NOMINEE,
JUDGE JACKSON, BECAUSE SHE
"MARRIED A WHITE MAN."
HE ALSO FILMED HIMSELF ON THE
STREETS OF NEW YORK SCREAMING
RACIAL SLURS AT ASIANS AND
HISPANICS AS THEY WALKED BY
TELLING THEM, THEY SHOULDN'T
EXIST.
AND ACCORDING TO SOCIAL MEDIA,
HE WAS ALSO A BIG SUPPORTER OF
LOUIS FARRAKHAN OF THE NATION OF
ISLAM.
NATURALLY THIS STORY WILL BE
SWEPT UNDER THE RUG BY THE MEDIA
MOB.
I GUESS FRANK JAMES PROBABLY
WON'T FIT THEIR POLITICAL
NARRATIVE.
ONE DISAPPOINTED FORMER HOST
TWEETED "POLICE SAY THE SUSPECT
AS A MALE BLACK."
HOW ABOUT WE JUST GET THE BAD
GUY AND WE PROTECT THE GOOD
GUYS, ALL PEOPLE.
ANYWAY, WE WILL GIVE
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S REACTION TO
THIS ATTACK, THE DETERIORATING
CONDITIONS IN AMERICA'S MAJOR
CITIES, LAW AND ORDER, SAFETY,
SECURITY, CAN'T PURSUE HAPPINESS
WITHOUT IT.
FIRST, MORE BAD NEWS FROM
BIDEN'S DISASTROUS ECONOMY.
HE THOUGHT IT WAS BAD YESTERDAY,
WE CAN NOW REPORT BRAND-NEW
NUMBERS OUT TODAY.
WHOLESALE PRICES HAVE SURGED BY
A WHOPPING 11.2%.
THIS IS THE HIGHEST INCREASE
YEAR-OVER-YEAR, EVER, AND
HISTORY.
IT WAS 1.6%.
IT WILL BE PASSED ON TO THE
CONSUMER.
WHOLESALE PRICE INCREASES ARE
PAID BY THE PEOPLE LIKE US THAT
BY RETAIL.
LOOK AT YOUR SCREEN.
WHOLESALE PRICES HAVE BEEN
RISING DURING THE ENTIRE BIDEN
PRESIDENCY MONTH AFTER MONTH,
WORSE AND WORSE, AND IF NOT
VLADIMIR PUTIN'S FAULT.
JUST LIKE INFLATION LIKE WE
SHOWED YOU LAST NIGHT ALSO HAS
BEEN ON A STEEP INCLINE EVER
SINCE THE DAY JOE BIDEN WAS
SWORN IN.
AS YOU CAN SEE RIGHT THERE, THAT
IS WHY THEY WERE RISING WAY
BEFORE VLADIMIR BEFORE
VLADIMIR PUTIN INVADED UKRAINE.
THIS IS AN EXCUSE, THESE ARE
THREE BIG LIES TOLD BY JOE BIDEN
AND OF COURSE, HIS MINIONS IN
THE MEDIA MOB.
KEEP IN MIND WHEN DONALD TRUMP
LEFT OFFICE, AN AVERAGE GALLON
OF GASOLINE AT THE PUMP WAS
$2.42.
INFLATION WAS ONLY 1.4%, NOT
8.5.
AND CLEARLY BIDEN'S GREEN NEW
DEAL, CLIMATE ALARMIST SOCIALIST
AGENDA IS AN UNMITIGATED
DISASTER.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO GRADUATE FROM
HARVARD OR MIT TO FIGURE THAT
OUT.
HE KILLED THE KEYSTONE XL
PIPELINE.
BY THE WAY, THE PREMIER AND
ALBERTA MADE THE STATEMENT THAT
HAD HE NOT STOPPED PRODUCTION,
IT WOULD BE FINISHED BY NOW.
AND WE WOULD BE IMPORTING
900,000 BARRELS OF OIL, CANADIAN
OIL, EVERY SINGLE DAY.
WE CAN GET BACK TO BUILDING IT
AND GET THAT OIL.
EVEN HELP OUR FRIENDS IN WESTERN
EUROPE.
THEY SPENT TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS
ON HANDOUTS.
THE ECONOMY IS NOW SUFFERING IN
EVERY WAY IMAGINABLE AND ABOUT
TO GET WORSE.
AS WE PREDICTED RIGHT HERE, WE
TOLD YOU ON MONDAY AT THE
NUMBERS ARE COMING OUT TUESDAY
AND WEDNESDAY.
WE TOLD YOU THAT JEN PSAKI,
JOE BIDEN AND COMPANY WOULD BE
FULL OF EXCUSES STARTING WITH
BLAMING VLADIMIR.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> TO THE PRESIDENT THAT
ACKNOWLEDGE ANY RESPONSIBILITY
FOR THE INFLATION WE ARE SEEING
NOW BASED ON THE DECISION HE
MADE COMING INTO OFFICE?
>> AS THE PRESIDENT HAVE TALKED
ABOUT QUITE A BIT, THERE'S A
RANGE OF FACTORS INCLUDING THE
PANDEMIC, THE IMPACT ON THE
SUPPLY CHAIN, AND WHAT WE TRIED
TO DO FROM THE BEGINNING IS TAKE
STEPS TO ADDRESS THAT.
SUCH A SIGNIFICANT DRIVER OF
THIS DATA AND AN INCREASE IN
ENERGY PRICES OVER THE LAST
MONTH PLUS SINCE THE INVASION OF
UKRAINE.
THAT IS BASED ON DATA WE HAVE
SEEN OUT THERE.
OUR EFFORT AND FOCUS HAS BEEN TO
TRY TO ADDRESS IT AND TAKE
MEDICATION PRICES DOWN LIKE
NUMBERS WHEN WE CAN.
>> Sean: IT SHE WOULD BE GREAT
ON MSNBC, BECAUSE THEY NEVER
TELL THE TRUTH.
SHE'S NOT FOOLING ANYBODY.
LOOK AT THIS POLL OUT TODAY.
A PLURALITY OF AMERICANS THINK
BIDEN IS THE MOST RESPONSIBLE
FOR THE SPIKE IN GAS PRICES AND
OF COURSE THE RECORD HIGH
INFLATION.
MORE NEW NUMBERS TODAY.
IT FOUND THAT THEY ARE PULLING
AND SHOWING JOE BIDEN'S APPROVAL
RATING AS ITS LOWEST POINT EVER.
33%.
ONLY 26% OF INDEPENDENTS APPROVE
OF JOE BIDEN.
TODAY, FIVE DIFFERENT POLLS HAVE
BIDEN UNDERWATER BY DOUBLE
DIGITS.
AMERICANS ARE NOT HAPPY.
BIDEN'S RELIGIOUS CLIMATE
ALARMIST POLICIES HAVE BEEN A
NIGHTMARE.
BUT INSTEAD OF GOING TO THE
SIMPLE ANSWER, CHANGING COURSE,
ADMITTING FAILURE, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION JUST DOUBLES DOWN
ON WHAT IS NOT WORKING.
TODAY BIDEN'S TREASURY SECRETARY
VOWED TO REDOUBLE HER EFFORTS TO
D CARBONITE IS OUR ECONOMY.
NO, WE SHOULD BE DRILLING, WE
SHOULD BE FRACKING, AND WE
SHOULD BE EXTRACTING COAL.
THAT IS THE LIFEBLOOD OF THE
WORLD'S ECONOMY.
BUT WHY GO FOR THE OBVIOUS?
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE CONFIRMED THAT OUR WINDOW
OF OPPORTUNITY TO LEAVE OUR
PLANET WORTHY OF OUR CHILDREN
AND OUR GRANDCHILDREN IS EVEN
CLOSER -- WE MUST REDOUBLE OUR
EFFORTS TO D CARBONIZED OUR
ECONOMIES.
RECOGNIZING THE COUNTRIES WE USE
A RANGE OF TOOLS INCLUDING
CARBON PRICING, REGULATION, AND
SUBSIDIES WE ACHIEVE REDUCTION.
THE ONE THEY D CARBONIZED AND WE
BECOME MORE DEPENDENT ON, LET'S
SEE, RUSSIA, IRAN, OPEC,
VENEZUELA.
NOT A GOOD PLAN FOR NATIONAL
SECURITY REASONS.
IN OTHER WORDS, EVEN LESS
DOMESTIC PRODUCTION OF THE
LIFEBLOOD OF OUR ECONOMY, WHICH
IS OIL, GAS, ET CETERA.
BECAUSE THAT WILL CONTINUE TO
RISE EVERY SINGLE WEEK, EVERY
SINGLE MONTH FOR EVERY SINGLE
AMERICAN.
WHAT IS THE DEFINITION OF
INSANITY?
IS THAT DOING THE SAME DUMB
THING OVER AND OVER AGAIN AND
EXPECTING A DIFFERENT RESULT?
THEY DON'T CARE IF YOU SUFFER,
THEY DON'T CARE IF YOU HAVE
TROUBLE PAYING YOUR BILLS, THEY
DON'T CARE IF YOUR LIFE GETS
WORSE, THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT THE
HIGH COST OF A GALLON OF
GASOLINE.
THEY JUST LECTURE YOU ON DRIVING
LESS AND GETTING ELECTRIC CARS.
MOST PEOPLE CAN AFFORD.
THEIR RELIGIOUS CLIMATE ALARMIST
CALL -- THAT I